TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan
and this is the Developer Show
on location at Google I/O 2016,
and I'm here with Noah.
We're going to talk
about Project Tango.
Now, there is a
Project Tango game
that people are
playing with here
in the Sandbox called "World."
Can you tell us a
little bit about it?
NOAH FALSTEIN: So
this is a game that's
being done by a new company
called [? Phenomena, ?] but
with some very old and
experienced game developers,
including a designer
called Keita Takahashi.
He worked on a game
called "Katamari Damacy."
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
an awesome game.
NOAH FALSTEIN: Oh,
just great stuff.
But very playful approach, and
he's brought that to "World."
It's a game where
you can actually
set up little things
in a virtual world that
are situated in the real world.
So as you move around
with the Tango device,
you can actually see them
from different angles
and set them up on the real
walls and floors of your room.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now,
you were telling me
a little bit earlier
about the first steps
you take into the game.
What is that like?
NOAH FALSTEIN: Sure.
Well, at the beginning, one
of the things that you do,
for example, is you're
given a little seedling,
and you can plant
that in the ground.
And then perhaps on a nearby
wall, you can take a cloud,
but the cloud is
actually on a spring,
so you put it on the wall and
it goes boing, boing, boing.
You can click on the cloud
and it starts raining,
and suddenly the seed will
sprout and turn into a flower.
So it's stuff everybody
understands intuitively,
but then you can
play with the stuff,
put the flower on top
of another flower,
have them start rotating,
make them bigger or smaller.
Whole thing just opens it up
as a playground for you to try.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Something I've heard
you talk about
before which I really
loved in Project
Tango is the ability
to make any space a
play space, which seems
to be evident in this game.
NOAH FALSTEIN: So one
of the great things
is that you can use the
Tango device to actually
have it be sort of a magic
window into a virtual world
that you create or has been
created by the developer
so that as you move
it around, it's
as if you're seeing right
into this other space that
isn't even there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
NOAH FALSTEIN: It's great stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: One more
general question for you.
What is your favorite
thing about being
a game designer and developer?
NOAH FALSTEIN: Wow.
I think the best thing
about being a game designer
is that you get to make
things that you enjoy,
that are fun, that please
the rest of the world.
It's pretty much like
other entertainers,
just a lot more nerdy than
being a rock star, for example.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Noah.
NOAH FALSTEIN: All right,
thank you, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Eitan, let's
talk more about Project Tango.
What do you say?
EITAN MARDER
EPPSTEIN: Absolutely.
Why not?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So there's
a handful of things
that I'd like to ask you about.
First off, it's been a few
months since we've talked,
and we talked a little bit
about stuff coming up at I/O
this year.
What are some of the highlights?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Yeah, so this year at I/O,
we've announced a
couple of things.
So the first one is we've
made some improvements
in our meshing
APIs, and the second
is that we're announcing
that a month from now
we're going to be releasing some
improvements in area learning
APIs.
And specifically,
we'll be correcting
for drift of the device as it
moves around an object that
should keep your augmented
reality content really fixed
in the world in a nice way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And that's really
key for augmented reality.
In fact, we talked to
Noah about "World,"
where it's kind of making
the real space around you
a play space by adding
virtual objects,
and something like
that drift compensation
would be really key for
keeping those virtual objects
where you place them.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Exactly.
You want to lock
those objects in place
relative to the geometry of
your physical environments,
and that's something
we're really
excited to be able to
provide to our developers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
are some of the coolest,
most exciting things
that they're working on?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Yeah, so this year
we're really excited
because we're
building real apps for
our consumer launch,
and we're showing some of
them in our booth today.
So we've got "Measurements,"
which I really like.
So you can use your Tango device
as a tape measure, measure
from the floor to the ceiling
or in hard-to-reach places,
measure things like areas
and volumes very easily.
Then we've got at-home
retail, so we've
got companies like
Lowe's and Wayfair
who are trying to place
furniture and kitchen
appliances into your home, let
you visualize how they look,
see how it fits in your
space-- make sure that you're
good to go before
you buy online,
and sort of reduce
the number of returns
and give people a better
sense of interior decoration.
And then we've got gaming.
So we've got "World"
by Phenomena,
we've got [? Trixy ?] Studios
with their [? "Phantageist" ?]
game.
And it's really exciting
to see people brought
into their environment,
engage with their environment,
but also with, like,
virtual creatures thrown
in for good measure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's so cool.